a federal judge in California ruled
overnight more overnight new is that the
Trump administration must reunite
separated immigrant families within 30
days the order after an ACLU lawsuit
also sets a 14 day deadline for children
under five to be reunited with their
parents the Health and Human Services
Department says more than 2,000 children
are still separated from their families
David Pegg now is in Mission Texas along
the us-mexico border David good morning
good morning those are the lights of
Mexico behind me John it was a week ago
today that President Trump signed the
executive order ending the separation of
families but the language in the order
didn't specify what would be done to
reunite those families already separated
so now you've got this ruling by a court
in California that is blistering
in its language it's a preliminary
injunction issued in the Southern
District of California by US District
Judge Dana Sabra which says the
government is blocked from carrying out
any future family separations the order
also says parents cannot be deported
before being reunited with their
children under the present system judge
savoir rights migrant children are not
being accounted for with the same
efficiency and accuracy as property
certainly that cannot satisfy the
requirements of due process we do not
want any children separated from their
parents any longer than absolutely
necessary under the law hours before the
judge's order president Trump's
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alexei zarf told Congress that the
government would not return children to
parents who are being held in customs if
the parent remains in detention
unfortunately under rules that are set
by Congress and the courts they can't be
reunified Azar's referring to the Flores
agreement that says that immigrant
children cannot be held in detention for
more than 20 days now HHS says there are
currently two thousand 47 children still
separated from their parents that's just
6 less than the number the government
gave us last week last week we had about
3100 apprehensions we had been
consistently over 4200 apprehend since a
week we went to see Border Patrol Chief
Manuel Padilla who runs the busiest
sector on the border he says last week
as the national debate was raging over
separating families the
number of apprehensions dropped
preliminarily what does that say to you
that it works having a consequence to
illegal entry works so that's what these
supporters of the president's policies
say but critics say even if it does work
it's immoral the Pope said that nor this
week we're told the first lady's going
to visit another facility where children
are being held awaiting reunification
maybe she can do something to help speed
up this process I'm glad you've updated
us on those numbers David thank you so
much